nonsectarian alliance market what they
said is they share with me the joy had
seen their tremendous concept arid
result well Mr Speaker I think that the
message I took from the local elections
is that what people on the doorstep want
is they want to see restored devolved
government as soon as possible and
that's what I'm working to deliver thank
you friend share my hose that having got
the local elections under our belts and
just on the cusp of the European
elections with both of those out of the
way a rarely firms positive focus can be
placed by all parties on restoring
devolved assembly battle stormer
mr. speaker I can tell my honourable
friend that I know that the parties in
Northern Ireland are determined that
they will do all they can to deliver
restored devolved government and that is
what is best for the people of Northern
Ireland it's what the people of Northern
Ireland want but this will not be easy
there are challenges and I would ask
that we all offer our support to the
parties in Northern Ireland to help them
take those difficult decisions one
sentence Jim Shannon
know what ii spit comment or like to
comment on the assessment of the
election of chrysler guard only former
spokesperson for 32 county sovereignty
movement in the electro area with a
murder of mrs. bystander Lamech II took
place and who are forward
unapologetically and n discriminate
towards police have based on this what
progress has been made and not a best
murder investigation on the process as
well the old gentleman's a fan of the -
in the semicolon to state mr. speaker
very good at the use of a sentence I
would just repeat but the lesson I took
from the local elections was that people
want restore devolved government as soon
as possible mr. speaker mr. mr. speaker
as the house heard earlier on and we had
over 17,000 responses to the
consultation many of them containing
tales of personal tragedy and loss so I
hope everyone will understand the need
to consider them all respectfully and
carefully the process is almost finished
and I hope we will be able to publish
and analysis of the views they contain
oh this is very unfair on the minister
who's answering a question about the
legacy of Northern Ireland's past this
is a matter of the utmost seriousness
and solemnity and I think that the
minister and the questioner should be
accorded respect the minister but thank
you Mr Speaker I was just finishing my
remarks by saying the process of
considering those tragic submissions is
almost finished I hope we'll be able to
publish an analysis of the views they
contain very soon Chris Davis Thank You
mr. speaker my friend agreed we must
listen carefully to this consultation
and does he agree with the words of the
Secretary of State in the foreword to
the consultation where she stated
amnesties am not the right approach and
believe that justice should be pursued
this is mr. speaker yes I do
I mean any solution must allow both
unionists and Republicans to achieve
closure and for all nor land to draw a
line and move on otherwise it will not
last we've been working closely with the
political parties in Orland as well as
colleagues across both houses on the way
forward and last week the secretary
State make the vitsin Commissioner and
legacy groups as well mr. speaker the a
part of the the dark past ignored now
and is also the question of historical
institutional abuse the Secretary of
State has said that she now intends to
act the victims groups this week called
on her to stand down and resign she
needs to regain their confidence she
needs to give a very clear timetable as
to when she will take action in this
house and elsewhere will the Minister
now make it clear when that will happen
I thought I heard just now the sector
snake doing a pretty good job of showing
the personal equipment and also the
urgency in which he's treating is I'm
afraid I can't add any more detail to
the term to the timetable but I hope
everybody here will have understood and
heard the passion in her voice and the
determination to move this forward
promptly and fit and swiftly Bob Stewart
mr. speaker my honourable and gallant
friend gave a a very powerful speech on
this on Monday and I would encourage
anybody here who hasn't heard it to go
back and listen again I think we both
agree he and I that the current
situation isn't working for anyone the
question isn't whether things need to
change because they clearly do but so we
have laws which work for police veterans
as well as armed forces for unionists
and for nationalists for victims and
their families on all sides of the
community and which bring truth and
justice and closure so society can move
on
we will bring football proposals as soon
as possible objects soldier now a member
of parliament
I'm ashamed ashamed that my government
hasn't sorted this batter out I asked
the minister and especially the
secretary state who's been post longer
how much longer before it could be
sorted out and are you not ashamed
Minister Mr Speaker I my honourable and
gallant friends having served himself in
Northern Ireland speaks with huge
Authority music in this area and I
suspect this is something which
successive governments need to share
some blame for failing to fix over many
years and it is clearly as I said in my
initial answer a situation which cannot
be allowed to continue it is not right
it is not just and it must be sorted out
as promptly as it can of that I hope he
and I I'm sure that he and I both agree
with regret yesterday we got a
revelation from government through
written ministerial statement rather
than an oral statement about their
proposals for the way forward and we
should hang our head and shyam that we
intend to treat service personnel who
served in Northern Ireland differently
from those who served overseas when I
questioned the Attorney General on this
issue on the 31st of January he said
clearly the to treat service personnel
differently would be clearly wrong he
was ranked Minister wasn't it
mr. speaker the important thing here is
that for the the service men and women
who served under Operation banner as
we've heard repeatedly in both the
urgent question last week and the
Westminster all debate on Monday for
those service men and women each felt
the same no matter what our challenge
though is to say that if we're going to
come up with an answer which will work
when it gets inevitably taken to court
by the law fair mongers that we have to
have something which works on the basis
of the different legal starting points
for things that happened in the UK as
opposed to things that happened too
broad but which end up at an answer
which feels the same to our servicemen
and women and provides the same robust
protections to them no matter what order
questions to the Prime Minister John
Woodcock question one mr. speaker the
Prime Minister thank you mr. speaker mr.
speaker today marks two years since the
Manchester Arena attack it was a
cowardly and sickening attack that
deliberately targeted innocent and
defenseless children members from across
the house will want to join me in
sending my thoughts and prayers to the
families and friends of all the victims
and I'm sure members will also want to
join me in paying tribute to the immense
bravery and courage that the emergency
services showed that night mr. speaker
this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house
I should have further such meetings
later today John Woodcock Thank You mr.
speaker I know the hope that the whole
house will want to associate themselves
with the words she has just spoken about
the Manchester attack now she may not
have long left and good luck with those
meetings later today but she can act now
against the return of banned chemical
weapons British experts are this morning
investigating a suspected chlorine
attack by al Assad in Eid Lib well if it
is proved will she lead the
international response against the
return of this indiscriminate evil is
Right to raise the issue of the evil of
the use of chemical weapons we of course
acted in Syria with France in the United
States when we saw chemical weapons
being used in Syria we of course
suffered the use of chemical weapons
here on the streets of the United
Kingdom and took a robust response
supported by our international friends
and allies and we condemn all use of
chemical weapons we are in close contact
with the United States we're monitoring
the situation closely and if any use of
chemical weapons is confirmed we'll
respond appropriately but our position
is clear we consider Assad incapable of
delivering a lasting peace and his
regime lost its legitimacy due to its
atrocities against its own Syrian people
Toinette son
does the Prime Minister agree that
energy efficiency measures are critical
in tackling and climate change
bringing every home up to a PPCC
standard could save 25 percent of
electricity generation area the
equivalent of six nuclear hate to point
nuclear power stations it could save
every family two hundred and seventy
pounds and it could potentially pay for
itself by generating one point two seven
pound one pound twenty-seven pennis for
every pound investment invested well my
I think my own boyfriend has made an
excellent point and we like her
absolutely recognize the importance of
this issue so the government is
committed to improving energy efficiency
in two and a half million homes by 2030
and our aim is to bring two and a half
million fuel poor homes up to an energy
performance certificate C rating by 2030
and as my little friend has said this
will indeed help to save energy and also
bring down bills Jeremy Corbyn Mr
Speaker I joined the prime minister in
commemorating all the victims of the
Manchester bombing two years ago our
thoughts are with the friends and the
family of all those that were killed the
survivors and of course the emergency
service workers who gave such heroic
service that night they live with the
horrors of this for the rest of their
lives and 10:31 tonight will be a very
poignant moment for many people in
Manchester Mr Speaker I also want to pay
tribute to the last survivor of the
whole headscarf revolutionaries Yvonne
Blenkinsop she's visiting Parliament
today she led a campaign for basic
safety on the UK's fishing fleets in the
1960s and as a result many lives were
saved
I think people like her have made such
an enormous contribution to our national
life they should be recognized for it
I also Mr Speaker want to express on
behalf of the Labour Party my outrage
that the government has again failed our
steel industry putting 5,000 jobs at
risk in British steel 20,000 more in
supply chain this government has failed
those people and even at this late stage
and there is a statement later on today
must step in to save those jobs
mr. speaker could ask the Prime Minister
why our schools having to close early on
Friday afternoon due to spending cuts
gentlemen because he has raised the
issue of British steel and obviously we
recognize that this is worrying time for
the thousands of dedicated British steel
workers and their families but also
those in the supply chain and local
communities we have indeed the
government has been working tirelessly
with the company with its owner Greybull
capital and lenders to explore all
potential options to secure a solution
for the company
we showed through the ETS agreement that
we were willing to act but we can only
act within the law and it is clear that
it would be unlawful to provide a
guarantee or loan on the terms requested
by the company we will be working with
the company and others and the official
receiver in the days and weeks ahead to
ensure that we can pursue every step to
secure the future of the operations
Scunthorpe skin in Grove and on T side
my right honourable friend the
Chancellor has also agreed an indemnity
for the official receiver to enable
British steel to continue to operate in
the immediate future there are no job
losses at this time and the official
receiver has already said staff will
continue to be paid and employed am i
right on will friend the business
secretary will be updating the house in
a statement later this afternoon and on
the issue of schools as the right
honourable gentleman knows we are
putting record levels of funding into
our schools well that would explain why
26 schools closed early on a Friday
every week because they don't have
enough money to keep themselves open mr.
speaker more than 1,000 schools across
England that are turning to crowdfunding
websites with a wish list of things they
want to raise money to buy really exotic
things like pencils like glue like
textbooks
why are they forced to do this if they
allegedly have enough money in the first
place
Prime Minister gentlemen's I've said
here before we am I just quoted we are
putting record levels of funding into
our schools we also put in place we've
also put in place to ensure a fair and
distribution of of the funding between
our schools we are giving every area
more money for every pupil in every
school but what what is important in our
education system it's not just about
what government puts in it's about what
educative education is received by the
children there are more children in good
and outstanding schools the
disadvantaged attainment gap has been
has been narrowed and record rates of
disadvantaged young people are going to
university that's a record to be proud
of I don't know if the Prime Minister
had a chance to listen to or read the
words of the the general secretary the
National Association of head teachers he
said and I quote the fact that so many
schools are doing this should be ringing
serious alarm bells for the government
the Prime Minister doesn't seem to be
aware of the crisis that's facing so
many in education at the present time so
can she be very clear with the house has
per pupil funding risen or fallen since
2010 we're giving every area more money
for every pupil in every school
[Applause]
why are we why are we able to do that
it's because the Conservatives have
taken a balanced approach to our economy
and manage our finances well what would
labour give us 1000 billion extra pounds
in borrowing that will mean higher taxes
fewer jobs and less money to go into our
schools route in two ways mr. speaker
one is a Labour government would
properly fund our schools it wouldn't
short a job
[Applause]
and we wouldn't use Orwellian words like
fair funding while we're cutting per
pupil funding mr. speaker just so the
Prime Minister understands it has fallen
by eight percent for six forms it's
twenty four percent at the end of last
year the Prime Minister said austerity
is over Maria who describes herself as a
teacher in an underfunded school wrote
to me this week and she asked this Maria
is a teacher an underfunded school I
think you need to listen to her when
will the government stop making false
claims of increased funding for schools
and start to tackle the serious problems
faced by teachers when will the cuts end
for our children's schools we are giving
every area more money for every pupil in
every school
but let's just see let's just see the
situation but this government inherited
then we would see under a Labour
government in the future having to spend
more on debt interest than on our
schools budget that's not because of
what this government is doing because
we're bringing debt down it's never it's
the legacy left by a Labour government
more money on debts than on our schools
this government has squandered is what
it inherited children centers shall
start children taken out of poverty it
squandered the future for so many of our
children order order mr. Burkhardt
you're an educated young man when you
came into the house she struck me as a
very well-behaved fellow calm yourself
and listen let me go in mr. speaker the
Department of Education is funding chief
met with school leaders recently and he
told them the first thing to say is
obviously they are not generous budgets
he's very very cautious with his words
they are budgets which leave schools
with real pressures to face everyone
agrees mr. speaker that our creative
industries in this country are an
enormous strength to our economy so why
then have the arts borne the brunt of
the government's brutal cuts to school
funding so many children losing out on
music and creative art in our schools
because of decisions made by central
government he started his question by
claiming that this government had
squandered what have been left by the
last Labour government let's just look
at what was left by the last
[Applause]
they don't want to be reminded what they
left in the last time they were in
government what did the last Labour
government lead unemployment higher than
when it went into office the Labour
government lead the biggest deficit in
our peacetime history and what would be
told by the departing chief secretary to
the Treasury under Labour there is no
money left my question mr. speaker was
actually about funding for arts and
creative subjects in schools a survey
has shown that 9 out of 10 secondary
schools have cut back on lesson time
Starfall facilities in at least one of
the creative arts subjects are the
artists and actors of tomorrow only to
come from the private schools while she
continues to cut the funding for state
schools when the prime minister says
that school funding has been protected
she's denying mr. speaker the daily
experience of teachers parents and
pupils she's denying the
incontrovertible evidence of the IFS
Education bodies and teaching unions she
is actually in outright denial and when
the wealth of the richest 1000 people
has increased by 50 billion pounds in
the last year alone don't tell us the
money isn't there for our children's
schools
this government has cut vital public
services to give tax cuts to the
privileged few can the Prime Minister
name a more damaging policy a more
short-sighted policy than cutting
investments in our future our children
honourable gentlemen the richest have
paid more tax every paid more under
every year under the Conservatives than
in any here under a Labour government
and he talks about what happens in our
schools as I said we are putting record
funding into our schools but what
matters is the quality of education that
our children get labour oppose the
phonics checks they want to scrap
academies and free schools
they'd abolish SATs that doesn't help to
raise the standards in our schools but
let's just look let's just look at the
labor record when they were in
government standards were lower than
they are today where they are in
government in Wales standards are lower
than in England and if they were to get
into government we would see more of the
same lower standards less opportunity
less opportunity for young people for a
brighter future under labour
it's the Conservative Party that give
good quality of education good
mr. Ronald J warden ah
my right humble friend explained why she
ordered that the consultation on the
troubles in Northern Ireland should not
contain proposals for a statute of
limitations as was reported in The
Sunday Telegraph and can she update us
on what the government will actually get
on and do shouldn't necessarily believe
all the reports he reads in the
newspapers but let me be very clear on
this particular issue around 3,500
people were killed in the troubles the
vast majority were murdered by
terrorists the legal position is clear
any amnesty or statute of limitations
would have to apply across the board it
would apply to terrorists I am not
prepared to accept a proposal which
brings in amnesties for terrorists
[Applause]
we'll set myself with the remarks of the
prime minister of the heinous crimes it
took place two years ago in Manchester
we all must stand together against
terrorism mr. speaker the Prime
Minister's customs tariff plan has been
described by the UK's former
representative to the EU as the
definition of insanity her Customs Union
compromised already dismissed by the
European Union isn't this new deal just
a fantasy I've set out the 10 points
about the new deal there is an issue
about customs there is a difference of
opinion in this house on the future
customs arrangement with the European
Union that's why it's important that
this house actually comes to a decision
on that issue the towering second
referenda
second reading of the withdrawal
agreement bill will enable this house to
come to a decision on that issue it will
also enable to the House to come to a
decision on a second referendum which I
continue to believe would not be the
right route for this country to go down
we should deliver on the first
referendum before suggesting anything
about a second let's talk about ignored
in reality Prime Minister look at the
benches behind you
the Prime Minister is filling no one but
herself and the truth mr. speaker is
that the people of Scotland don't want
her deal her own party doesn't want her
deal and now even the pro brexit labour
front bench once supported deal her time
is up tomorrow people in Scotland have a
choice to send the message to send
pro-european outward-looking Scottish
National Party
to Brussels to start brexit Prime
Minister what party does she think the
people of Scotland will choose there is
only one party in Scotland guaranteeing
no more referendums and that's the
conservative
[Applause]
thank you sir
[Applause]
colleagues calm yourselves dignity
restraint
let's hear mr. Heep II my constituent
Jackie Luxan was 26 weeks pregnant at
the time of a car crash that caused her
baby to be stillborn
however only the injuries calls to mrs.
Luxan and their older daughter where
relevant were relevant when charging and
subsequently sentencing the driver who's
dangerous driving caused the crash the
baby grace got no justice at all and I
understand from the police and
stillbirths support groups that the
luxans tragic experience is sadly far
from unique for the prime minister look
again at the 1988 Road Traffic Act so
that those who cause death to viable
babies over for 24 weeks gestation
through dangerous driving can be held
responsible first of all I know there's
all members from across the house and it
will have been obvious in the response
to his question who want to join me in
sending deepest sympathies to my other
friends constituent as my only friend
will know that courts can already and do
consider harm caused to a mother or
unborn child in sentencing for an
offense and I know my honourable friend
has discussed changing the law on this
particular issue with the Ministry of
Justice they are concerned that there
could be far-reaching unintended
consequences of doing so but I have
asked them to keep the law under review
I know the my noble friend along with
others in this house will be continuing
to work on this issue I thought
everybody recognizes the compassion that
my honourable friend is showing in
raising this issue what we want to
ensure is that what he is proposing is
not something that could lead to other
unintended consequences of the sort that
he would not wish to see Ronnie Cowan
[Applause]
it's been brought to my attention that
some children suffering from severe
epilepsy but able to greatly reduce and
in some cases end their seizures if
they've got access to bed relate due to
the cumbersome and discriminated system
this government implemented on the 1st
of November 2018 teams are required to
travel abroad pay thousands of payments
and break the law to bring medicine back
or the extraordinary places to access
bed rate privately in the UK rather than
people have to fight for access or a
case-by-case basis
all the payments are placed on common
stings and you're a super song of
compassion and do everything she can to
make made your cannabis available to
many people that are suffering and sure
that those who can benefit do can I can
I say to the Honourable gentleman that
these are I fully understand that these
cases are desperately difficult and my
sympathies are with the families and
friends the government did change the
law as he said and specialist doctors on
the General Medical Council specialists
register can now prescribe cannabis
based products for medicinal use where
there is clinical evidence of benefit
NHS England and the chief medical
officer have made it clear that cannabis
based products can be prescribed for
medicinal use in appropriate cases but
we must trust doctors to make clinical
decisions in the best interests of
patients given all in right Thank You
mr. speaker
when Sally Masterson discovered a 1
billion pound fraud at Lloyds the bank
sought to discredit her to the regulator
constructively dismissed her and
prevented her working working with the
police investigation who had described
her role as vital five years later the
bank apologized and paid an undisclosed
amount of compensation yet the FCA
continued to refuse to investigate would
the Prime Minister use her powers to
compel them to do so and sanction those
responsible including if relevant the
chief executive at for those five years
Antonio Horta Osorio
it's important to remember that the
events at H post-reading branch
constituted criminal activity and it's
right that those responsible were
brought to justice
the FCA are currently conducting two
investigations into the events at h bas
reading including the bank's
communications with regulators following
the discovery of the misconduct and
Lloyd's have appointed a former High
Court judge Dame Linda Dobbs to consider
whether issues related to H bowls
reading were properly investigated and
reported by Lloyds Banking Group those
findings will be shared with the FCA and
I look forward to the conclusion of all
those investigations Davey Perkins mr.
speaker Brampton primary school in
Chesterfield has an exemplary record in
special needs education yet under the
government's funding formula the first
six thousand pounds very special needs
child isn't actually funded by the
government well even the Tory lead
member for education in Derbyshire
describes his call-up Brampton as a
victim of their own success isn't it
time that the Prime Minister in her
final days changed the funding formula
and started looking after those special
needs children we have been putting more
money into special educational needs
I recognise I recognise I recognize that
for many parents getting the support
that is really required for their
children can be a difficult process with
the with the local authorities we
recognise the importance of special
needs and that is precisely why we were
putting it being putting extra support
in there
the surrounds the birds mr. speaker
could I thank the Prime Minister for the
amount of British aid which flows
through to the World Food Program in
Yemen and ask if she's noted in the last
twenty forty eight hours a report by its
excellent director David Beasley drawing
attention to the diversion of Aid and
the theft of aid in hootie controlled
areas by hootie authorities which he
urged the international community to
increase the pressure on Hootie
leadership to resolve this and and
further the efforts for peace in Yemen
rather than take the slightly easy
course of always focusing on the Yemeni
government and the saudi-led coalition
my friend raises a very important point
we are all concerned about the
Planetarium situation in the Yemen as he
rightly says this government has a good
record in terms of the amount of money
that we are providing the aid that we
are providing to help those in the Eman
but of course it is only of benefit if
it is able to reach those who need it
and it is incumbent on all parties to
ensure that that aid reaches those who
need it we will continue to support the
efforts to bring a lasting peace to the
Yemen a political settlement there is
the way to get that sustainable that
sustainability and security for the
future but it's incumbent on everybody
to make sure that the a that is being
provided for those who are desperately
in need is able to reach those who need
it most the UN logo
Thank You mr. speaker on the fifth of
June the eyes of the world will be on
Portsmouth for d-day seventy-five events
planned will give justice to the
sacrifices made by veterans like my own
grandfather and will show Portsmouth to
be a place that fosters a legacy of
remembrance reflection and
Reconciliation our allies in World War
two Australia New Zealand Canada and the
US have all taken the steps to ensure
coroners record suicide amongst the
veteran community Prime Minister why
don't we it is indeed right that the
eyes of the world will be on Portsmouth
for the d-day national commemoration of
event this will be putting our veterans
first it remembers their sacrifices
their achievements and we will highlight
the historic strength of the Western
alliance and the transatlantic
partnership he's raised a specific issue
in relation to the coroner's reports and
I write to him on in response to that
but can I say that I look forward as do
others to being in Portsmouth to
commemorate this very important
anniversary mr. Ian Duncan Smith mr.
speaker 43 years ago I like many others
was ordered to serve in Northern Ireland
to keep the peace by terrorists
attacking and killing civilians in
Northern Ireland many of my colleagues
and others did not come back including
one Robert and Iraq a friend who was
tortured murdered and his body has never
been found and all his murder has ever
been brought to justice I simply say to
my right honorable friend that in answer
to our right our honourable friend
earlier question she talked about an
amnesty I must tell her that none of
those who served have called for an
amnesty what they have called for is
fairness and justice many many old
veterans now are finding having been
cleared decades ago that the PSNI has
now proceeding against them with no new
evidence
can I please ask her will she answer me
how is it that I can say to my old
colleagues that this government has not
abandoned them we absolutely value the
service that he and others did in
Northern Ireland this was a very
difficult time for a part of the United
Kingdom and the work that the police did
and that the Armed Forces did in
Northern Ireland during that time was
absolutely crucial we are pleased that
we've seen the peace that has come since
the Belfast Good Friday Agreement but
there were there was obviously much
injury and loss of life during the
Troubles as I indicated earlier around
3500 people were killed during the
Troubles the vast majority of those were
murdered by terrorists my right
honourable friend talks about a fair and
just system we want to ensure that there
is a fair and just system that is
working across the board to deal with
these legacy issues
but what is happening at the moment is
that there is a disproportionate
emphasis in terms of cases that involve
the police and the Armed Forces there
are cases involving terrorists that are
being looked into but I think people
would recognize that there is a
disproportionate emphasis on the police
and Armed Forces what is important is
that we therefore bring in the system
which has full support and which will
enable people to see that fairness and
justice being applied that is what the
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
is working on she has been working on
that with the various political parties
in Northern Ireland and it is what we
will in due course put forward we
recognize the sacrifice and the bravery
and determination of our armed forces
and the work they did in Northern
Ireland and we too want to see fairness
and justice but the Prime Minister has
now recognized that say No Deal brexit
is not a viable option but she knows as
well as the rest of us that many of her
potential successors do not feel the
same way so can she tell us whether she
agrees with her brexit secretary amongst
others who thinks that we should be
spending the coming months
stepping up preparations for a No Deal
brexit or with her Chancellor who is
issued an edict that no more Treasury
money should be spent on preparing for a
No Deal brexit there is only one way of
this house ensuring that it leaves the
we leave the European Union without no
deal and that is to leave with a deal
and that is to support the second
reading of the withdrawal agreement bill
and take that process through this
through this house but the Honourable
lady antral also knows that the legal
default position continues to be no deal
were it were we to get to the 31st of
October situation I want us to leave the
EU before then but were we to get to the
31st of October a position it will be a
matter for the 27 not just for this
country to determine whether there was
no deal or not and that is why it is
absolutely right that the government is
continuing to make preparations for no
deal Charles Walker thank you very much
mr. speaker mr. speaker like so many
people in this chamber I want to see
more moneys for schools
hospitals the police and transport is
not is not the best way of doing this to
a greer deal that allows us to legally
exit the EU thereby unlocking three
years of pent-up investment sitting on
the sidelines seeking certainty that the
Prime Minister is trying to deliver this
party should be trying to deliver
well my honor but my honorable friend is
absolutely right there is pen top
investment there there are companies
who've been holding investment back
until they see the brexit deal being
resolved and it is important that we do
see that deal going through this house
supporting the withdrawal agreement bill
is the way to ensure that we deliver the
brexit that the people voted for and we
do it in a way that conservative stood
on in their manifesto at the last
election and actually that the Labor
Party members stood on in their
manifesto at the larcs election once we
are over this once we have left the
European Union then we will be able to
take advantage not only of the deal
dividend but of that increased
investment and seeing that bright future
for our country yes miss mr. speaker as
a Manchester in Peake and I thank the
prime minister and the leader of the
Opposition for their words of
remembrance for the victims of the
terrorist attack in our city two years
ago in the light of concerns expressed
about delays in accessing compensation
and the amounts offered to victims
following the attack will the government
give consideration when the criminal
injuries Compensation Scheme is reviewed
this year to establishing a separate
government funding pot for victims of
terrorist attacks so it doesn't have to
be taken from the criminal injuries
compensation Authority funding and so we
can give more flexible and immediate
support to victims of terror attacks the
Honourable gentleman has has raised a
very important point and I recognised
the force with which he's raised a ton
concern he has for those who were the
victims of the of that terrible attack
and of course sadly in this country we
have seen too many people being victims
of terrorist attacks the Lord Chancellor
has indicated that they the Ministry of
Justice is reviewing this situation he
has heard the specific proposal that the
Honourable gentleman has put forward and
I'm sure will take that into account in
that review react or feel
Thank You speaker returning to Northern
Ireland it's now two and a half years
there's been no devolved government in
Northern Ireland and every week on the
Northern Ireland Affairs Select
Committee we hear about the impact of
this on ordinary people whether it's
some quality issues whether it's funding
for the PSNI whether it's a high-rise of
teachers were paid 6% less than there
were teachers in the rest of the United
Kingdom Northern Ireland is being left
behind will the Prime Minister - all she
can to restore devolution before the end
of the year give my honourable friend
that reassurance I am as key as she is
to ensure that we cease restoration of
devolution in Northern Ireland I believe
that that recently all the parties have
come together with talks with the
Secretary of State and and as
appropriate the Irish government and are
ensuring that those we are ensuring
those talks are continuing obviously
there are issues that need to be
addressed concerns from the political
parties on different issues those need
to be overcome such that we can see
devolution restore because as my
honourable friend says this is a matter
for the people of Northern Ireland and
to ensure they have a devolved
government that can ensure that good
government's in northern up Northern
Ireland Thank You mr. speaker on two
previous occasions I rushed the Prime
Minister to do more to support the
victims of the leasehold scandal now
that she's about to move house any time
soon will the PM give that a little more
focus and urgently address this issue
and give lease holders justice listening
to those who've raised concerns about
this particular issue last year of
course my right on will find the housing
secretary announced no new government
funding scheme will be used to support
the unjustified use of leasehold for new
houses we have had a technical
consultation on how to improve the
market for consumers we're analyzing the
responses to that will respond to that
and the recent Select Committee report
on these hold reform shortly and we will
introduce legislation in due course it
replies to my right old friend for
Chingford wood for gree the Prime
Minister quite rightly paid tribute to
the 300,000 security personnel who
through their courage professions and
skill maintained the rule of law without
which the Belfast agreements would never
have been signed direct but she didn't
quite answer his question none of those
people who serve defended the rule of
law want a blanket amnesty what they
want is a categorical surance that the
prosecuted prosecuting authorities
within the existing framework of law
will not bring forward a fresh process
and then these categorical clear new
evidence and there is an assurance and
no doubt whatever that a fair trial will
proceed and I absolutely appreciate the
point that here in our right honourable
friend Amanda 13-foot and wood green has
made in relation to this issue the
problem we face in Northern Ireland is
that there have been a number of
processes which have been aiming to deal
with these these issues and justice in
relation to these deaths during the
during the Troubles but all of the
processes that have been followed so far
have been found to be flawed in some way
that is why it is necessary to go
through this that the work that we have
been doing to find a process the
will not be flawed that will be legally
supportable and that will enable the
fairness and justice that we all want to
see to be brought to the fore Laura
Smith 17 election campaign the Prime
Minister acknowledged that our social
care system is broken and promised to
fix it yet the CEO of a care provider in
Crewe and Nantwich recently told me that
the decision to cut sleep him pay for
care workers by up to 400 pound a month
is a direct result of underfunding in
the care sector will the Prime Minister
consider bringing legislation to ensure
sleep in ships attract at least the
national living wage and provide the
necessary funding to local authorities
so that it is possible to give care
workers the pay that they deserve Prime
Minister issue of sleeping cover has and
paying for sleeping cover has been one
that the government has been dealing
with and that we have had to address
this as a direct result of a court case
that was that was taken we have been
responding to that court case I
recognise the issue about the question
of pay for sleep in sleeping cover and
it's one and under in relation to the
wider issue of Social Care yes we are
going to bring forward proposals in
relation to Social Care we want to
ensure that we have a sustainable social
care system for the future all in Latham
welcome with me the the launch of radio
reminisce a fantastic new dimension
friendly radio it's a subscription-based
radio service designed to help and
comfort people over seventy with early
onset dementia produced and developed in
belfry Michael
Minister I can I say to my honourable
friend I first like I thank her for
raising this issue and for raising the
issue of support particularly with
people with early onset dementia and for
highlighting this new radio service as
she will know the government is
committed to double spending on research
and dementia by 2020 but in relation to
the radio service this is obviously a
very practical way of providing support
for people with early onset dementia and
I'm happy to join my honorable friend in
welcoming this excellent radio service
I'm sure it's going to provide very
important help to those who are
suffering with dementia the prime
minister must be considering her legacy
and she said she wanted to correct
burning injustice so will she commit to
supporting legislation such as that
proposed by my honourable friends the
member for Kingston upon Hull North so
that abortion in Northern Ireland
becomes a health not a criminal matter
and that as soon as possible
women have equal rights across the whole
of the United Kingdom my view on the
what should happen in relation to
abortion has been clear I've made that
clear in the past but this is a devolved
issue and we believe this is something
that should be addressed by the devolved
administration in Northern Ireland
well that's restored he Baker to speaker
as we look forward to the visit by the
President of the United States will the
Prime Minister
well my right honourable friend agree
with me that it is in the national
interest that we support his visit unite
across
to make success of the visit so there
are special relationship in Jaws and
grows and supports the success of this
country as we exit New Year can I thank
my own girlfriends raising this issue
and he is absolutely right we are
looking forward to the state visit of
the President of the United States we're
also looking forward to the fact that
President Trump will be joining myself
and other leaders to commemorate the
75th anniversary of d-day this is an
important commemoration when we will be
recognizing as I said earlier in
response to the Honourable member from
Portsmouth the sacrifice that was made
by British Armed Forces by American
armed forces and others from so many
other countries to ensure the freedom of
Europe and my own boyfriend is also
right we have a deep and special
relationship with the United States of
America it is important that is our
closest security and defense
relationship our deepest security and
defence relationship it is a
relationship that has helped to keep a
peace around the world it is one we want
to see continuing at every member of
this house should welcome the president
of the United States of America here to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have repeatedly heard from the Prime
Minister and it would be and I quote an
unforgivable breach of trust in our
democracy
if we fail to deliver brexit yet if the
polls are correct Scotland be sending a
clear message tomorrow that it wants to
remain in Europe by increasing its
number of SNP ami peace while swiping at
the Tories
should Scotland increase its number of
crew EU Amy pieced morale will the Prime
Minister finally listen to the people of
Scotland who want to determine their own
future
as an independent European nation or war
they've reached their first leaving
Scotland's people with Boris's brexit
Breton I suggest if the Honourable
gentleman wants to listen to the people
of Scotland and there their view on
their future he actually starts
listening to the decision they took in
2014 to remain part of the United
mr. speaker if polling is to be believed
the winning party in tomorrow's your
elections will be the brexit party this
party in contrast to the vote leave
campaign in 2016 is clearly stated that
No Deal brexit is its policy on the
basis of normal turnout that means that
between 6 & 7 million people will have
voted for No Deal which begs the
question what are the other 10 million
brexit voters in 2016 it concerns me as
long concerned me that we don't have the
consent here in this house to deliver
the brexit that is likely to emanate
from this house with that in mind and I
congratulate to the Prime Minister on
the first steps yesterday towards
acknowledging this because she commits
towards working reaching out across this
house in order to bring about the vote
which remains to take place which is the
choice between having a final say of the
British public or a No Deal bricks I I
don't recognise actually the choice that
he has set out and for this reason first
of all as I said earlier I have not
changed my view on a second referendum
I've been clear that I believe this
house should be delivering on the result
of the first referendum and the choice
that is before this house I believe is
the whether or not it wants to deliver
on the result of the first referendum
and deliver on the manifestos on which
the majority of members of this house
stood which were clear that we wanted to
do that with a deal we can do that we
can do that by giving second reading to
the withdrawal agreement bill and seeing
that bill through this house seeing that
bill get Royal Assent ratify the treaty
and leave the European Union Universal
Credit was today condemned again by the
UN Special Rapporteur who likened dwp
policy to creating modern versions of
19th century work houses
a leaked memo has revealed that the DWP
is doubling down promoting universal
credit with an aggressive PR campaign
including a BBC documentary an advert
seen in today's Metro which DWP official
state and I quote won't look like DWP or
universal credit you won't see our
branding and this is deliberate Prime
Minister how is it right that the DWP
is spending hundreds and thousands of
pounds or misleading adverts that
promote a cruel policy which is driving
my constituents into debt despair and
destitution pensions is doing is
spending not just its resources but its
effort and I thank all the staff in DWP
for this in out there helping people
into the workplace and ensuring that
when they're in the workplace they are
able to keep more of the money that they
earn Steve two years ago the Prime
Minister visited the fishing village of
medica see I'm sure she remembers it
because she bought me some chips for
lunch
the people are never gizzy now face
losing their only GP surgery because the
remaining doctor there has given notice
to hand back the contracts to the NHS
I'm sure the Prime Minister will greet
me that is vital that these rural
coastal communities retain their primary
care services so what more can the
government do to attract GPS to rural
and coastal communities and will she use
her office's to ensure everything
possible is done to make sure member
gissy
keeps its GP service well can I think
for my own defence reminded me of the
visit to the beautiful member gissy and
also reminding him about the very good
chips that I think he and I both shared
on that on that occasion he's absolutely
right he's absolutely right about the
importance of GPS to local communities
and I recognise the concerns that there
are in a vacancy on this issue and what
we are doing is giving additional
incentives to attract GP trainees into
areas that are previously hard to
recruit areas such as rural and coastal
communities but I'm sure that the
minister a minister from the Department
of Health and Social Services social
care will be happy to meet my little
friend to discuss this particular issue
dogs Thank You mr. speaker for for over
two years now the victims and survivors
of historical institutional abuse in
northern I'll have been waiting for
justice and compensation following the
independent report of Mr Justice harder
acts just as hard the fact of the matter
is many of them are dying without seeing
the compensation come through the NI use
policy of refusing to do anything in
Northern Ireland even when it does cross
community and cross-party support has
now come to the culmination of victims
of abuse dying without seeing justice
this has got to stop will the Prime
Minister intervene and make sure that
action is taken to get immediate action
for these victims appreciate the extent
of concern that there is about this
issue of course we have the wider we
also have our independent inquiry into
child sexual abuse hearing in in
and I recognize that the impact on all
those who have been victims of this sort
of abuse we call it historical you
reverse the the the investigation is
referred to as historical investigation
for those who have been victims
it is not historical it rests with them
for the rest of their life
I recognize the concern about the issue
that he has raised obviously if the
North Ireland Executive were in place
this would be a matter that the
Northland exception would be no it would
be a matter of Northern Ireland
Executive would be addressing my right
or my friend the Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland has been looking at
this issue and I will help discuss with
her what response can be given on what I
recognize is a matter of deep concern to
many people in Northern Ireland Mr
Speaker I have a question to the prime
minister from the Northern Ireland
veteran his role marine David Griffin a
Dublin born Irish Catholic who joined
the British Army transferred to the raw
Marines in 1972 in Belfast he killed an
IRA gunman who was about to assassinate
one of his comrades at a guard post 47
years later he is now being investigated
by the PSNI he is watching these
proceedings now prime minister from his
home at the Royal Hospital in Chelsea he
asked me to ask you this I served my
Queen and country in uniform for over 20
years and I was commended for my service
in Northern Ireland acting under the
lawful orders of my officer commanding I
killed a terrorist who was about to
murder one of my comrades and yet I'm
being investigated as if I were a
criminal the IRA have letters of comfort
we don't why Prime Minister are you
pandering to SH in vain IRA while
throwing veterans like me to the wolves
what is your answer Prime Minister
this Chelsea pensioner and all the
veterans he represents Minister can I
say to my honourable friend he has put
his case and that of the veteran he's
represented a Chelsea pensioner and we
thank that individual as we do all those
who served in Northern Ireland for their
bravery and the determination with which
they acted in Northern Ireland which as
my right honourable friend earlier said
for Northern Ireland secretary said
enabled the peace that we see today in
Northern Ireland to take place it is not
the case that the terrorists have an
amnesty currently if there is evidence
of no if there is it has been made very
clear that evidence of criminal activity
will be investigated and people should
report to justice what I want to ensure
what what I want to ensure is that we do
have a fair and just system at the
moment I do not believe this the system
is operating fairly I don't want to see
a system where there is an amnesty for
terrorists I want to see a system where
investigations can take place in a
lawful manner where the results of those
investigations can be upheld and will
not be reopened in the future and in
order to do that we need to change the
current system and that is what we will
do over the last few days I've received
distressed emails from a number of
constituents who are EU citizens living
in the UK but who won't be able to vote
tomorrow their predicament arises
because of the Prime Minister's
government's late decision to
participate in the elections which
didn't give many EU citizens enough time
to fill out the necessary form to
clearing that they won't be voting
elsewhere well the Prime Minister use
all the power of her office to take
immediate steps this afternoon to make
sure that the necessary forum is of made
available at polling stations tomorrow
so the EU citizens living in the United
Kingdom won't be disenfranchised
what can I say to the Honourable Lake
believe that we take every step to make
sure that those are entitled to vote in
elections are indeed able to do so but
can I just say she says it was a lake
decision by the government to enter into
the European elections of course that
decision was taken because of a decision
by this house not to agree on the 29th
of March that we would agree the deal
such that it would not have been
necessary to hold European elections
Johnny Mercer thank you very much mr.
speaker I think the Prime Minister in
this house is beginning to understand
the level of fury of veterans in this
country when it comes to their treatment
by this place over the years but the
most disturbing part of last weekend is
this insinuation of equivocation between
those who got up in the morning to go
and murder women and children and
civilians and those who've donned a
uniform to go and protect the crown here
the Prime Minister take this opportunity
now to tell the nation she sees no
equivocation whatsoever between those
two groups and that the line that
preferential treatment should not be
given to veterans is not right I say to
my honourable friend it is absolutely
clear I would have hoped from everything
that I have said at this despatch-box
but I value the sacrifice the bravery
the commitment of our armed forces whose
work in Northern Ireland alongside the
police in Northern Ireland and others
enabled us to get to the stage today
that we have the Belfast Good Friday
Agreement and the piece that we have had
in Northern Ireland for many years now
and long may that continue there is no
question of equating that bravery and
that sacrifice with the acts of
terrorists
but what I would also say to my
honourable friend is that what he is I
think from implication of his question
urging me to do is to put into place a
system which would equate terrorists
with members of the armed forces any any
statute of limitations any amnesty that
is put into place would as a matter of
law have to apply across the board I do
not want to see and I will not see an
amnesty for the terrorists Thank You mr.
speaker can I thank the Prime Minister
for recognizing the impact on steel
workers and their families of the
devastating news that British Steel has
gone into liquidation and also thank her
for recognizing the high quality of work
that they do on Teesside skinning Grove
and that indeed it's come up in my
constituency will she meet with MPs
cross-party affected by this and so that
we can look together about how best to
make sure this great industry moves
forward in the future serving this
country what can I say to the honourable
gentleman I said earlier I recognize
this is a worrying time for his
constituents and others and the
government has been looking actively at
what we can do as I say we've given the
support we did through the ETS agreement
but haven't been able nor felitti to
give the further support that was
requested but I'll certainly meet with
him and a group of MPs to consider this
issue this is about one company owned by
grey bull Capital but obviously we have
taken steps in the past to ensure that
we continue to have a steel industry in
the United Kingdom and we will want to
look at that wider issue order
just before we come to the statement by
the Prime Minister I think it is fitting
colleagues for me to refer again to
something that was mentioned at the
start of questions to the prime minister
today by the leader of the Opposition
three trawlers set out from Howell
during January in February of 1968 and
never returned
leading to the loss of 58 lives Yvonne
Marie Blenkinsop is the last surviving
member of a group of women from Hull who
became known following that tragedy as
the headscarf
revolutionaries the women campaigned for
better protection for their husbands
fathers brothers and sons through their
actions countless lives have been saved
I am reliably informed that Yvonne Marie
Blenkinsop is with us today observing
our proceedings we salute we extend the
warmest welcome to Tina
from
Buddha statement the Prime Minister
thank you Thank You mr. speaker and with
permission before I make my statement
may I to recognize the work of Yvonne
Marie Blenkinsop and others and indeed
all those over the years who have
campaigned to ensure that those in the
workplace can have the degree of safety
and security that they need with
permission Mr Speaker I would like to
make a statement on the government's
work to deliver brexit by putting
forward a new deal that members of this
house can stand behind we need to see
brexit through to honor the result of
the referendum and to deliver the change
the British people so clearly demanded I
sincerely believe that most members of
this house feel the same but for all our
division and disagreement we believe in
democracy that we want to make good on
the promise we made to the British
people when we ask them to decide on the
future of our EU membership as to how we
make that happen
recent votes have shown that there is no
majority in this house for leaving with
no deal and this house has voted against
revoking revoking article 50 it is clear
that the only way forward is leaving
with a deal but it is equally clear that
this will not happen without compromise
on all sides of the debate that starts
with the government which is why we've
just held six weeks of detailed talks
with the opposition talks that the
leader of the Opposition chose to end
before a formal agreement was reached
but which nonetheless revealed areas of
common ground and having listened to the
opposition to other party leaders to the
devolved administration's to business
leaders trade unionists and others we're
now making a 10-point offer to members
across the house ten changes that
addressed the concerns raised by
honorable and right honourable members
10 binding commitments that will be
enshrined in legislation so they cannot
simply be ignored and 10 steps that will
bring us closer to
a bright future that awaits our country
once we end the political impasse and
get brexit done first we will protect
British jobs by seeking as close to
frictionless trade in goods with the EU
as possible while outside the single
market and ending free movement the
government will be placed under a legal
duty to negotiate our future
relationship on this basis second we
will provide much-needed certainty for
our vital manufacturing and agricultural
sectors by keeping up-to-date with EU
rules for goods and agri-food products
that are relevant to checks at the
border such a commitment which will also
be enshrined in legislation will help
protect thousands of skilled jobs that
depend on just-in-time supply chains
third we will empower Parliament to
break the deadlock over future customs
arrangements both the government and
opposition agree that we must have as
close as possible to frictionless trade
at the UK EU border protecting the jobs
and livelihoods that are sustained by
our existing trade with the EU but while
we agree on the ends we disagree on the
means the government has already put
forward a proposal which delivers the
benefits of a customs union but with the
ability for the UK to determine its own
trade and development policy the
opposition are both sceptical of our
ability to negotiate that and don't
believe an independent trade policy is
in the national interest they would
prefer a comprehensive customs union
with the UK say in the u trade policy
but with the EU negotiating on our
behalf as part of the cross party
discussions the government offered a
compromise option of a temporary customs
union on goods only including as UK say
in relevant EU trade policy so the next
government can decide its preferred
direction but we were not able to reach
agreement so instead we will commit in
law to let Parliament decide this issue
and to reflect the outcome of this
process in legislation forth to address
concerns that a future government could
rollback hard-won protections for
employees we will publish a new workers
rights bill as I've hold the house many
times
successive British administration's of
all colors have granted British workers
rights and protections well above the
standards demanded by Brussels but I
know that people want guarantees and I'm
happy to provide them if passed by
Parliament this bill will guarantee that
the rights enjoyed by British workers
can be no less favorable than those of
their counterparts in the EU both now
and in the future and we will discuss
further amendments with trade unions and
business v the new brexit deal will also
guarantee there'll be no change in the
level of Environmental Protection when
we leave the EU and we will establish a
new and wholly independent Office of
Environmental Protection able to uphold
standards and enforce compliance six the
withdrawal agreement bill will place a
legal duty on government to seek changes
to the political declaration that will
be needed to reflect this new deal I'm
confident we will be successful in doing
so
seventh the government will include in
the withdrawal agreement bill at
introduction a requirement to vote on
whether to hold a second referendum I've
made my own view clear on this many
times I am against a second referendum
we should be implementing the result of
the first referendum not asking the
British people to vote in a second one
what would it say about our democracy if
the biggest vote in our history were to
be rerun because this house didn't like
the outcome what would it do to that
democracy and what forces would it
unleash but I recognise the genuine and
sincere strength of feeling across the
house on this important issue so to
those MPs who want a second referendum
to confirm the deal I say you need a
deal and therefore withdrawal agreement
bill to make it happen let it have its
second reading and then make your case
to Parliament
if this house votes for a referendum it
would be requiring the government to
make provisions for such a referendum
including legislation if it wanted to
ratify the withdrawal agreement 8th
Parliament will be guaranteed a much
greater role in the second part of the
brexit process the negotiations over our
future relationship with the EU in line
with the proposal put forward by the
Honourable members for Wigan and
stoke-on-trent central the new brexit
deal was set out in law that the House
of Commons will approve the UK's
objectives for the negotiations and MPs
will also be asked to approve the treaty
governing that relationship before the
government signs it 9th the new brexit
deal will legally apply to the
government to seek to conclude the
alternative arrangements process by
December 2020
avoiding any need for the Northern
Ireland backstop coming into force this
commitment is made in the spirit of the
amendment tabled by my honourable friend
the member for altering him and sail
west passed by this house on the 29th of
January and while it is not possible to
use alternative arrangements to replace
the backstop in the withdrawal agreement
we will ensure they are a viable
alternative
and finally 10th we will ensure that
should the backstop come into force
Great Britain will stay aligned with
Northern Ireland we will prohibit the
proposal that a future government could
split Northern Ireland off from the UK's
customs territory and we will deliver on
our commitments to Northern Ireland in
the December 2017 joint report in fall
we will implement paragraph 50 of the
joint report in law the Northern Ireland
Assembly and executive will have to give
their consent on a cross community basis
for new regulations which are added to
the backstop and we will work with our
confidence and supply partners on how
these commitments should be entrenched
in law so that Northern Ireland cannot
be separated from the United Kingdom
following the end of au election perder
the withdrawal agreement bill will be
published on Friday so the house has the
maximum possible time to study its
detail if Parliament passes the bill
before the summer recess the UK will
leave the EU by the end of July we will
be out of the EU political structures
out of ever closer Union we will stop
British laws being enforced by a
European core
we will end free movement we will stop
making vast annual payments the EU
budget by any definition that alone is
delivering brexit and by leaving with a
deal we can do so much more besides we
can protect jobs guarantee workers
rights maintain the close security
partnerships that do so much to keep us
all safe we will ensure that there is no
hard border between north and ireland
ireland and we can bring an end to the
months years of increasingly bitter
argument and division that have both
polarized and paralysed our politics we
can move on move forwards and get on
with the jobs we were sent here to do
what we got into politics to do that is
what we can achieve if we support this
new deal
reject it and all we have before us is
division and deadlock we risk leaving
with no deal something this house is
clearly against we risk stopping brexit
altogether something the British people
something the British people would
simply not tolerate we risk creating
further divisions we risk creating
further divisions at a time when we need
to be acting together in the national
interest and we guarantee a future in
which our politics become still more
polarized and voters increasingly
despair as they see us failing to do
what they asked of us none of us want to
see that happen
the opportunity of brexit is too large
and the consequences of failure too
grave to risk further delay so in the
weeks ahead there will be opportunities
for MPs on all sides to have their say
to table amendments to shape the brexit
they and their constituents want to see
mr. speaker in time another Prime
Minister will be standing at this
despatch box but while I am here I have
a duty to be clear with the house I have
a duty to be clear with the house about
the facts if we are going to deliver
brexit in this Parliament we are going
to have to pass a withdrawal agreement
bill and we will not do so without hold
votes on the issues that have divided us
the most that includes votes on customs
arrangements and on a second referendum
we can pretend otherwise and carry on
arguing and getting nowhere but in the
end our job in this house is to take
decisions not to dock them so I will put
those decisions to this house because
that is my duty and because it is the
only way that we can deliver brexit so
let's demonstrate what this house can
achieve let's come together honor the
referendum deliver what we promise the
British people and build a successful
future for our whole country and I
commend this statements to the house
[Music]
Thank You mr. speaker I thank the Prime
Minister for an advanced copy of this
statement in fact I received it
yesterday when the Prime Minister made
an appeal entitled seeking common ground
in Parliament and where did she make
that appeal not in Parliament but in a
small room just down the road mr.
speaker it's now clear the bold New Deal
the Prime Minister promised is little
more than a repackaged version of her
three-times rejected deal the rhetoric
may have changed but the deal has not I
thank the Prime Minister for her letter
it offers no change on a customs union
no change on single markets alignment
and no dynamic alignment on
environmental protections this covenant
is too weak to divided to get this
country out of the mess that they have
created for over two years the Prime
Minister bullish Lee refused to consult
the public or Parliament she did not
seek a compromise until after she'd
missed her own deadline to leave and by
the time she finally did she had lost
the authority to deliver that became
evident during the six weeks of
cross-party talks that ended last week
talks that were entered into
constructively on both sides to see if a
compromise was possible but mr. speaker
while those talks are going on cabinet
minister after cabinet minister made
statements undermining what their
colleagues in the room were offering the
foreign secretary lead with the house
international trade secretary and
treasury chief secretary all made clear
they would not tolerate a deal which
included a customs union while tory
leadership contender after tory
leadership contender took it in turns to
make it absolutely clear that any
compromise deal would not be honored
therefore mr. speaker no matter what the
Prime Minister offers it's clear
no compromise would survive the upcoming
Tory leadership contest the multiple
leaks reported from the cabinet
yesterday show the Prime Minister
couldn't even get the compromise deal
she wanted through her own cabinet and
it's clear at the shrunken offer that
emerged satisfied no one not our own
backbenchers not the DUP and mr. speaker
not the official opposition either no
Labour MP can vote for a deal on the
promise of a prime minister who only has
days left in her job and even if the
Prime Minister could honor her promises
the deal she is putting before us does
not represent a genuine compromise her
10-point plan is riddled with
contradiction and wishful thinking
firstly the Prime Minister pretends
she's delivering something new with a
temporary customs union this isn't a
compromise
it's just accepting the reality under
the withdrawal agreement we will already
be in a temporary Customs Union through
the transition period which can last for
up to four years and if not we will
enter the backstop which in effect keeps
us in a customs union - without any say
secondly why would this house legislate
for a plan which has already been
comprehensively rejected by the European
Union the government wants to align with
the European Union on goods to keep
frictionless trade while at the same
time wants to pursue trade deals which
would undermine this process it's simply
not compatible the technology they need
to continue to pursue their checkers
plan simply doesn't exist it's already
been ruled by the EU as illegal
impractical and an invitation to fraud
and mr. speaker
the government has failed to provide any
economic analysis to show this would
make us better off why would the house
support such a chaotic and desperate
approach labour set out a sensible
compromise plan over a year ago
including a comprehensive and permanent
customs union with the EU that gives us
a say that would allow us to strike
trade deals as part of the world's
biggest trading bloc bringing investment
while maintaining at the highest
standards it's credible and achievable
and the best way to protect industry
manufacturing of jobs something this
government is woefully indifferent to as
the latest crisis in the steel industry
shows today the government must be
prepared to step in and take a public
stake to save thousands of high-skilled
jobs a British steel a foundation
industry for any major economy instead
the Tory obsession is for striking trade
deals with the likes of Donald Trump
they prioritize chlorinated chicken
further NHS privatization and
deregulation over protecting supply
chains and jobs in this country on
workers rights Mr Speaker we have yet to
see the full package the government
intends to bring forward but many many
in the trade union movement remain very
skeptical as Francis O'Grady of the
trade union Congress said yesterday and
I quote this reheated brexit deal won't
protect people's jobs and rights on
environmental protections it's clear the
Prime Minister is not offering dynamic
alignment and that under her proposals
the United Kingdom would fall behind in
a number
of areas with only a toothless regulator
under the control of the Environment
Secretary in place of binding
international commitments to protect our
environment finally mr. speaker on the
issue of a confirmatory vote I'm sure
nobody here will be fooled by what the
Prime Minister is offering will the
Prime Minister tell us now if this offer
is genuine will she give her party a
free vote on this issue or will she as
before as before with against a
confirmation referendum if the
government if the government truly
believes this is the best deal for the
economy and for jobs they should not
fear putting that to the people mr.
speaker for too long for too long our
politics has been seen through a prism
of leave or remain this this is dividing
dividing our society and poisoning our
democracy it means vital issues vital
issues are being neglected the crisis in
our schools and hospitals the housing
crisis and the cruelty of the social
security policy and universal credit our
country needs leadership to bring us
together
however this Prime Minister is not the
person to do that throughout the last
three years she's made no attempt to
unite the country she's been focused
only on keeping her divided party
together and it hasn't
and her time the time has now run out
she no longer has the authority to offer
a compromise and cannot deliver that's
why it's time for a general election to
break the brexit deadlock and give the
country a say thank you
Thank You mr. speaker but I think I
think the game was actually given away
by the right honourable gentleman when
he made it absolutely clear that as far
as he is concerned the way to get this
through the house is for everybody else
to compromise to his plan and only his
path he in his statement he was very
clear that he was not any making any
proposals to compromise the government
has indeed compromised we have
recognized that the real issues on which
this house will need to decide and that
is the plain fact there are different
opinions across this house on the two
key issues of the future customs
arrangement and the second referendum
I've made my position very clear on
these the government has set out its
position but it is for this house to
decide and the best vehicle to do this
is within the withdrawal agreement bill
so then this house can finally make its
mind up as to what it wants the future
customs arrangement to be and as to
whether it thinks there should be a
second referendum he talks about free
votes on a second referendum well of
course in the indicative vote process
that went through we did indeed give
conservative members a free vote on this
issue and the second referendum was
rejected across the house he talks about
he has some he has some inaccurate
comments he talked about the
environmental regulator it will be an
independent body which is able to hold
the government to account on the issue
of environmental standards I think he
showed his blinkered view on trade when
what he sets out is as far as the he
seems to be concerned the only issue the
only people he wants to trade with a
European you
actually what we want to see is a good
trade deal with the EU and good trade
deals with other countries around the
world that is the best way way forward
for the United Kingdom and he talked
about British steel and I've answered in
response to questions in p.m. queues on
British school and what the government
is doing he talks about the government
labor position of wanting a
comprehensive customs union and of
wanting all that dynamic alignment and
that single market I have to say to the
right honourable gentleman that what the
Labour Party wants to achieve in its
relationship with the EU would make it
even harder for a British government to
take action to protect industries like
the steel industry he himself has always
complained about state aid rules but he
would be wanting to tie himself into
those state aid rules by what he is
proposing for the future and then but
then of course what we see he talks he
talks about different opinions he talked
about different opinions across this
house of course the one issue that has
never properly been resolved in this
house and which the withdrawal agreement
bill would force to be resolved in this
house is whether the right honourable
gentleman himself is for brexit or
against it if he is for brexit he will
vote for the withdrawal agreement bill
voting against the Whizzer all agreement
Phil is voting against brexit
[Music]
mr. Ian Duncan Smith mr. speaker can I
send my right honourable friend that the
this morning our Environment Secretary
was on the radio and when asked whether
this was certain that this second
reading would be brought back to
Parliament he didn't answer in the
affirmative he said they would take
reflections and they would listen my
questionnaire part of the prime minister
is having presented as a despatch box is
she absolutely certain now that she will
bring this bill back to the house for a
second reading and if so could she name
the date now and then say she would
stick to it and we've already made the
government's position clear in relation
to this but the second reading of the
withdrawal agreement bill will be
brought to the house after the whitson
recess mr. Ian Blackburn
[Music]
Thank You mr. speaker it is customary to
thank the Prime Minister for advance
sight of a statement it was some
surprise but we all saw the statement
been delivered not in the House of
Commons but elsewhere yesterday can I
ask the prime minister why we didn't
forward the usual protocol and
Parliament is the first to hear such
statements mr. speaker let me give the
Prime Minister some friendly advice this
deal is dead stop the charade and let's
get on with putting the decision back to
the people once and for all
the headlines this morning cry of doom
the benches opposite concentrate on ways
to mount our leadership coup and where
are they that's exactly what they're
doing this afternoon because they're not
here to support the Prime Minister this
is no way to run the government the
Prime Minister is asking MPs to vote for
a deal that takes Scotland out of the
single market and eventually out of the
customs union this simply cannot be
allowed to happen this is a rookie
government attempting to blackmail MPs
look behind the smoke and mirrors a new
revised deal that hasn't even been
negotiated with Brussels a second EU
referendum but only if you vote for the
bill a possible temporary customs union
which he future UK government could
change and the European Union have
dismissed a tree tariff arrangement
which the former UK representative to
the UAE EU has described as the
definition of insanity mr. speaker none
of what the Prime Minister announced
yesterday was discussed with the
devolved government in Edinburgh
this really goes to the heart of the
problem in December 2016 the Scottish
government published be compromised
position this was rejected without
discussion Scotland's voice has been
ignored time and time again brexit has
been our stripped away from the Scottish
Parliament there is no respect for the
devolved administration's by this
government Westminster has ignored
Scotland mr. speaker this is he sorry
miss look around there is no support for
the Prime Minister's deal Prime Minister
this deal faces in even bigger defeat
than the last vote tomorrow communities
won't make their voice heard and our
democratic European election mr. speaker
a vote for the Scottish National Party
is abort to stop brexit he got to stop
this economic madness he bought to
respect Scotland's decision in 2016 the
Prime Minister has lost the confidence
of a party Parliament will not support
her and she has lost the trust of the
people it is time Prime Minister T gold
will you do it
[Music]
to the right honorable gentleman that I
think he talks about the discussions
with the Scottish Government of course
there have been many discussions with
the Scottish government both I have met
the First Minister my right honourable
friend the chance to the Duchy of
Lancaster has held a number of meetings
the Scottish Government the devolved
administration's have been a party to
the debates and discussions that have
been an ability of being taking place
but can I just say this to the right
honourable gentleman he says that a vote
for the Scottish nationalists is a vote
not to leave the European Union well a
vote a vote for the Scottish
nationalists is a vote to betray our
democracy a vote to betray the view of
the people of the United Kingdom people
asked us in this house to deliver brexit
we have a responsibility to do that the
question is how we do that
withdrawal agreement bill gives the
opportunity to debate those issues about
how we do that and I save the right
honourable gentleman that this house
should have those debates come to the
decision stop ducking the issues and get
on with the job the British people
instructed us to do so John redwood what
does the Prime Minister say to their any
members of the public who think the
government should have kept its promise
to take us out on the 29th of March with
or without the draft treaty and what
does she say to those millions of angry
leave voters who do not see the
agreement as any kind of brexit but a
lock-in for many many months with no
clear way out can I say with the
greatest of respect to my wife
honourable friend but what I would say
to those voters who expected us to leave
on the 29th of March is that the
government's position was that we should
leave on the 29th of March the majority
of the government benches voted for us
to leave on the 29th of March
sadly the opposition and some others
voted to keep us in at that date
Hilary Ben thank you very much indeed
mr. speaker given that this bill appears
to have been sunk even before its
publication the prime minister must know
that the only way now to break the
deadlock which is today's terrible music
British steel shows is damaging our
economy as to be for us the choice back
to the British people to the right
so can I urge face eleventh-hour to take
that one final step to change her mind
and to say that she'll say to the world
a confirmatory referendum is I've
indicated in a number of answers to
questions this afternoon I have not
changed my view on the issue of a second
referendum I do believe we should be
reflecting the view that putting into
place the views of the people in the
first referendum that took place on this
issue but I recognize there is no
strength of feeling in this house on
this issue including from the right
honourable gentleman and others on his
Honda particularly on his benches oh and
that is why it is important that we are
able in this house to determine this
issue that is best done through the
passage of the bill through the passage
of the withdrawal agreement bill and
that is why I said what I did yesterday
it's why I said what I do have done
today on confirming that there will be a
vote on a second referendum whether to
hold a second referendum in the
withdrawal agreement bill the
government's position will be clear that
we don't think it right to hold a second
referendum but it will be for members of
this house to be able to come together
and to determine that view and for those
who believe there should be a second
referendum to be able to put their case
to the house and for the house to come
to its decision so when in cash the
minister tells us that if NPS vote
fitted with your agreement bill which we
haven't even seen let alone the
amendment so they're going to be put
down to it then we would leave the
European Union by the 31st of July
because I have been discussing and
business managers have been discussing a
timetable for putting this bill through
and the timetable for obviously a
business motion program motion has to be
agreed in this in this house but it is
very clear and the result of the last
the determination last European Council
makes it clear that on the timetable
that we would be possible to put through
giving bringing the bill back for second
reading in the after the Whitson recess
it would enable us to do exactly what I
said and leave the European Union on
31st of July that Cooper given the awful
news about British steel it's crucial
that the government stands up for
British manufacturing the Prime Minister
will know that a customs union is
immensely important to manufacturing
across the north and Midlands and also
that industry needs a long-term deal to
support investment so given the reports
coming out of cabinet yesterday can she
tell us has the cabinet ruled out a long
term Customs Union being part of the
future partnership with the EU that they
are supposedly going to negotiate after
this withdrawal agreement have they
ruled out a long term customs union yes
or no can I say first of all to the
right honourable lady she reference what
has happened to Grable capitals company
British steel she won't be aware as
others will that there are a number of
issues a number of challenges that are
facing the steel industry not just here
in the UK but globally and part of that
of course is the open capacity issue
because supply is outstripping demand
and of course much of the excess
production is coming from China that is
why in the g20 two years ago to three
years ago we acted to bring China around
the table to try and deal with that
issue she asks about the long term the
CompTIA compromise solution that I put
forward and referenced in my statement
on the customs is designed to ensure
that a future government can take
in the direction that it wishes to take
it and for the house to determine what
those negotiation negotiating objectives
should be what matters to our
manufacturing industry is the frictions
that take place at the border and having
the benefits of the customs union in no
tariffs in no quotas that is exactly
what is already in the political
declaration the benefits of the customs
union as I say we're committed to
ensuring that trade is as frictionless
as possible Nicky Morgan it's quite
difficult to make any judgments about a
bill when it hasn't been published and
if there were issues with perder then
the announcement should not have been
made this week next week this house is
in a recess which is very nice for all
of us but it's not needed given the
seriousness of the situation I will
probably vote for the bill when it comes
back but please can I ask the prime
minister to reflect very carefully on
whether it should be put to Parliament
because the consequences of it not being
passed are very serious and if she
really wants to heal the divisions to
get on with it I would ask her to
reflect very seriously about this bill
not being put to Parliament early June
and being allowed more compromised more
time being taken can I say to my right
honourable friend that the she is right
that if the bill is not passed then
we'll be faced with a very stark choice
and that choice will be whether they go
for no deal or whether they go for
something which is either revoking
article 50 or a second referendum with
the intention that many have in asking
for a second referendum to stop wrecks
it and that will be the choice that will
face this house which is why I say and
people talk about the compromises that
have been made so far there are people
who telling me that I have compromised
too much in the package that's been put
forward others who are telling me I have
not compromised enough in the package
that has been put forward at some stage
the house has to come together and we
have to take go and decide the distance
that we will go to
gather in order to deliver brexit and
deliver on what people asked us to do
mr. Nigel Dobbs mr. speaker the Prime
Minister has referred a lot on this
statement than yesterday to the new deal
the new practice obtained the book isn't
it the fact that the deal itself hasn't
changed the treaty is as it is these are
a series of domestic legislative
provisions to try to mitigate what is in
some cases a very bad deal but will
actually change the brexit deal itself
and to illustrate that the alternative
arrangements proposal which he has put
forward seeks merely to legally obliged
the government to conclude its own
processes but would she confirm that
there's absolutely no obligation on the
European Union to agree alternative
arrangements and indeed the final
decision as to whether they accept them
or view them is reasonable it's entirely
a matter for them would even be a matter
of objective assessment if a member
state government decides that they'd
rather keep those in the customs union
then that's what will happen there will
be no means of getting out of it we have
put forward to the House today a package
of proposals it is a new package of
proposals the right honourable gentleman
has been clear that in relation to the
operation of the backstop one of his key
concerns was making that UK wide that
commitment is there in the state that
the time that made today and as I said
we are happy to sit down and discuss how
we can ensure that these are enshrined
in in law which I know has always been
an issue of concern to the right
honourable gentleman the is regards to
the alternative arrangements the groups
to do that work being set up by
government the money being afforded by
government to do that work
but the European Union were clear and
they have committed themselves in the
legally binding commitments that have
been made at recent council meetings
that they will also work with us to
ensure that those alternative
arrangements are in place and are
available by in December 2020 have the
European Union agreed to any changes to
the withdrawal agreements which are
legally binding in international law
friend on others on many occasions and
the EU Council has made it clear on many
occasions that they are not reopening
the withdrawal agreement what we have
done in the processes that we have that
we took through the house up until up
until now to the most recent discussions
with the European Union is being able to
have certain legally binding commitments
made by both the UK and the European
Union in addition to the text of the
withdrawal agreement which cover a
number of issues that have been of
concern to people in this house Kendyl
does the Prime Minister understand that
she will not get enough support from
members on this side of the house to
allow her withdrawal agreement to pass
unless she includes a confirmatory vote
on the face she has come to the end of
the road exactly but it's true and
indeed any Conservative MP who wants to
stop the Prime Minister's successor from
inevitably pursuing a no deal brexit
they must back giving the public the
final say time is running out Prime
Minister please change your mind
and I say this is an issue on which as I
say there are very strong feelings
across this house I have met with
members from all sides of this house who
support a second referendum and have put
forward their case with their sincere
belief in that second referendum I have
a different view I do believe we should
be delivering on the first referendum
but I believe this is because of the
strength of view across this house on
both sides of the argument it's
important that the house has the
opportunity properly to consider it in a
way that is appropriate and that is
through the withdrawal agreement bill
Hobart one of the ironies of resigning
from government is it gives you rather
more freedom and emphasis when you
choose to support the government rather
than just oppose it and I will be
supporting the prime minister's bill can
I thank her for her efforts and ask her
to recognize there is still many people
in the country who believe that the best
future for the UK outside the EU is with
a compromise deal based on the interests
of both rather than a reckless and
increasingly bitter pursuit of a single
type of No Deal leaving at the cost to
many businesses to industry to
agriculture and a cost of the country so
expertly skewered by the part by the
Chancellor in his speech yesterday
what can I say to my right honourable
friend I do indeed agree with him that I
think there are many people across this
country who want to see us leaving the
EU in an orderly way and with a deal and
indeed that was the manifesto and watch
he on which he and I and are those of us
who sit here as conservatives stood at
the last election we stood to deliver
the best possible deal for Britain as we
leave the European Union delivered by a
smooth orderly brexit with a new deep
and special partnership including a
comprehensive free trade and customs
agreement with the European Union those
are the objectives that I have been
pursuing I've put forward today a new
package that does change the situation
that was been voted on previously and I
hope ever all those who want to leave
the European Union with a deal will
indeed support it in 1992 the Prime
Minister and I toured the working men's
clubs of Northwest Durham and I was
hugely impressed with her resilience in
front of audiences that were as hostile
to her as they were indifferent to me
but it turns out it turns out indeed it
turns out that the audience behind her
is tougher still she will fail in her
bid in two weeks time because people
behind her who are for brexit refused to
vote for brexit that is not her fault
but it is her problem so for old times
sake I want to help her out if she will
agree to put her deal which to be fair
to her is the only concrete void the
present we have yet seen to the British
people in a complementary vote then I
will join her in the lobbies will she
help me to help her
the right honorable gentleman and I
fondly remember those days in 1999 - -
up in Northwest Durham but can I also
say to him but I think if if this house
does not pass the withdrawal agreement
bill if this house does not enable the
treaty to be ratified then what this
house is saying is that it does not want
to leave the European Union with a deal
I believe the majority of people in this
house do want to leave with a deal this
is the vehicle to do it
Richard drags speaker now correctly
barato depend on two points that she's
made today the first she said that it
was up to the house to decide about a
customs union and a second referendum
can I correct it is not up to MPs to
decide that the country decided to leave
any AV the EU it's as simple as that
it's not for the house and the second
point when she responded to my right
over Frankel Wokingham she said that we
couldn't have left that you on the 29th
of March the legal position was that we
could but that she and dare I say a very
heavy remain cabinet decided not to take
his own I and my colleagues across
government voted to leave the European
Union on the 29th of March we continue
to believe that the best way to leave
the European Union is with a deal that
is the manifester on which my honourable
friend and I both stood in the last
general election and I believe it's
important that we that we recognize that
and that we deliver that for the for the
British people the point that he makes
about whether it is for the house to
decide the British people voted to leave
I have been trying to leave the European
I am looking forward to voting a fourth
time to leave the European Union in
withdrawal agreement bill
sadly opposition members and some of my
colleagues have not voted alongside me
in that in that in that way but how we
do that how we do that is a matter for
this house because the deal has to be
ratified by this house and this and
government and this house have to
determine what the objectives for the
next stage of negotiations are going to
be now I've been clear that those
negotiations will be taken ahead forward
by somebody else leading this government
but what I'm also clear about you can't
get on to those second stage of
negotiations until you get over the
first stage that's what the bill is
about speaker the prime minister's
statement referred rightly to the need
to avoid the risks that are inherent in
the brexit process but doesn't she
realize that her later latest proposals
actually hardwire those risks into the
process themselves gentlemen is talking
about the issues on which there is a
significant division in this house
namely customs and a second referendum
and taking those through in the
withdrawal agreement bill and what the
government is doing is committing to
ensure that those issues can be
addressed during the passage of the bill
the reality is in the way legislation
works in this house that any bill
brought before the house people would
put amendments and you know and
amendments could be seen on a whole
range of issues including those issues
but the key issue is what is determined
by this house in response to those
issues this house will have to come to a
decision
maybe James speaker on the basis of the
negotiations thus far what arrangements
alternative to the Irish backstop does
my right honourable friend consider our
most capable of agreement well the
number of set of proposals have been put
before the European Union which have a
number of elements in them bringing
together both technological approaches
some of which can be I think improved as
we see technology developing but also
the key issues that have been for debate
so far in discussion so far are those
around elements of the delegation from
EU law which will be necessary in order
to enable the alternative arrangements
to provide for the no hard border in the
way that both sides intended to do the
several Roberts with respect the Prime
Minister is asking us to put our faith
in her deal as frankly Authority is
slipping from her grasp with every
passing hour the Tories have had three
years to agree a deal among themselves
including weeks of full-on collaboration
with labour yet there's no guarantee
she'll be in a place to bring this bill
back next month how that's what can we
believe there's any guarantee of a
people's vote when she cannot even bring
herself to put it on the face of the
bill can I say to the right honourable
lady she and I have a different view on
the issue of a second referendum but
what I'm saying is that that is an issue
which we will make sure that this house
is able to determine the right
honourable lady wants to ensure those
those are people's vote and but it will
be for this house to decide whether or
not now it's already been rejected by
this house but it will be for the house
to come to a decision on that issue and
the house to accept that decision Lord
thank you Mr Speaker we cannot continue
to leave our country in this uncertainty
this has to stop the whole house needs
to stop saying no to everything on the
table just because it's not our
favourite
the EU negotiations actually they need
to stop saying no to every time we have
an issue as well but we have to end this
uncertainty if we vote for this bill we
can move on and the discussions on the
next stage can start yeah but Prime
Minister what happens if we say no again
my honourable friend is absolutely right
that we do need to be able to move on
and we can move on while respecting the
wish of British people by taking this
bill through by ensuring that we ratify
and that believe the European Union if
people in this house chooses not to take
this bill forward then it is facing
itself with a choice as to whether it
wants
No Deal or no brexit that is the choice
that will be available to people in this
house I believe I still believe there's
a majority in this house that want to
deliver on the referendum result but to
do so with a deal this is the bill that
enables that to happen
Jeremiah mr. speaker it's clear that the
house is going to reject the Prime
Minister's deal for a fourth time and
she's indicated that she will then set
out a timetable for her departure she's
also just said that there's no mandate
here to leave without a deal or indeed
the country so with regard to that
timetable if it is the case that a
change in Prime Minister occurs near the
end of October leaving her successor no
time to negotiate a further extension
will she herself request a further
extension before the September recess to
stop us leaving with no deal the
honourable gentleman knows I'm sure my
answer that which is if he really wants
to ensure that we do not leave the
European Union without a deal and the
best way is to agree a deal and that is
the bill Richard Graham
saddest irony that those are my
colleagues who most want to leave the
European Union have so far frustrated us
from doing so by voting with labour and
the Scottish nationalists and the Prime
Minister is quite right to highlight the
dangers of Parliament not supporting
withdrawal greement bill the day before
the European elections which none of us
on this side wanted to happen does she
agree with me that the superficially
seductive line from the brexit party
just leave on WTO turns holds enormous
dangers above all for our farmers and
from manufacturers and that this line
would in fact cause the breakup of the
United Kingdom how can I say to my
honourable friends that he is absolutely
right particularly in the point that he
makes about the dangers of an Odile
brexit for the future of the United
Kingdom and that is a main concern McKey
concern that I have in relation to that
issue and but it is also I think
surprising to see some of those who at
the time of the referendum at the time
of encouraging people to leave we're
talking about leaving with a deal about
being like Norway about accepting those
sorts of restraints on the ability of
the United Kingdom now not being willing
to accept what is a good deal for the UK
what enables us to to ensure that we can
leave with a deal that is good for the
future of the of the UK when people come
to vote at the European elections
tomorrow they have an opportunity to
vote for a party that not only believes
in delivering brexit that can do it and
that is the conservatives joanna cherry
mr. speaker the Prime Minister has said
that this 10-point offer was framed
after listening to the devolved
administration's yet there's nothing in
it to address the concerns expressed by
Scotland's government the cross-party
majority in Scotland's Parliament and
the majority of Scottish members elected
to this house know that her days of
sneering at the democratically elected
representatives of voters in Scotland
are nearly at an end it does she
concedes that her successor will need a
more intelligent approach to Scotland
than she has felt able to adopt
I say to the Honourable lady we have
consistently engaged with the Scottish
government we have consistently engaged
with with the Welsh government
throughout these throughout these
discussions and negotiations that we've
had in relation to our future in the
European Union but can I also say to the
to the Honourable lady that what is
important is that we all recognize the
responsibility that we have to deliver
on the vote that took place in 2016 -
well can I say to the honourable lady
she says she doesn't have that
responsibility she is she is an elected
member of this house and she has a
responsibility in the votes that she
casts she has said consistently she said
consistently that she doesn't want us to
leave without a deal that can only
happen if we have a deal or of course if
we choose to stay in the European she
says that we have not that we have not
listened to the Scottish Government what
the Scottish nationalists have made
clear at every stage is now is that they
wish to revoke article 50 they wish to
go back on the referendum result of 2016
and they wish to keep the United Kingdom
in the EU the majority of the British
population do not finish public do not
want that they want a party in
government and they want
parliamentarians in this house to
deliver on what they asked us to do mum
nail mr. speaker
the Prime Minister rightly referred in
her statement
this is a most extraordinary situation
the Honourable gentleman is seeking to
ask a question and he's been effectively
heckled and prevented in a seemly way
from doing so by the chance ring from a
sedentary position in pursuit of
Scottish tribal warfare by the
Honourable member calm yourself man the
Prime Minister / be able to look after
her so she was asked a question she's
given an answer there can be differences
of opinion and interpretation as to what
is the responsibility of a member of
parliament and those issues have been
aired the Honourable gentleman hasn't in
any way benefited the mix by his
disorderly chanter mr. Bob Neel Thank
You mr. speaker the Prime Minister
rightly referred in her statement to the
importance of leaving in a way which
maintains the closest possible security
policing and judicial cooperation with
the uu twenty-seventh that we have at
the moment the Justice Select Committee
was given clear evidence by the head of
the National Crime Agency that to do
otherwise would severely impair our
ability to fight organised crime and
terrorism and keep our country safe does
she agree that to fail to leave without
a deal to fail therefore to pass the
only available means of leaving with a
deal will be to put the security of the
country at risk and that is not
something that any member of this house
responsibly could contemplate doing my
humble friend is absolutely right to
raise the issue of security it is one
that is rarely raised in these debates
the majority of questions tend to be
about the economic relationship in the
trade relationship but the security
relationship is fundamental to us being
able to keep ourselves safe oh that's
why I'm pleased that we've negotiated in
the political declaration the strongest
possible security relationship with the
EU for the future for any country that
will be outside the European Union but
of course if we were to leave with no
deal then those security relationships
would not be open to us could we
negotiate some for the future that is of
course possible but it would require
that further negotiation and at the
point of leaving those security
relationships would be stopped
Caroline Flynn
to speak I agree with Lee right on a
remember for love bruh who's left the
chamber now but the essence of what she
was saying was everyone should take a
breath and take stock of what is on the
table look at the published bill when it
arrives on Friday but also I think to
all colleagues across the house be
mindful of the results of the European
elections the Prime Minister has said
several times already that if the second
reading of this bill does not succeed
there will not be another opportunity to
leave with a withdrawal bill the only
course and direction were to believe
without any deal at all and does she
agreed with me that anybody on whatever
side of the house if they claim to begin
Snowe deal they should give this
proposition without any any commitments
right now they should give this
proposition it's due consideration think
about how they will amend it and as my
honorable right honorable friend for
Ponte Kraft said recently in a newspaper
report stop the shouting and start
agreeing on what we can agree to move
forward the right honourable lady she is
absolutely right and that is that the
point of the process of legislation that
we have in this house is that once we
are beyond second reading of the bill it
will be open to members across the house
to put amendments down to the bill and
to have those debates about the precise
detail about how we are leaving but
anybody who wants to ensure that we
leave with a deal and that we don't see
a No Deal situation should support that
second reading enter into that debate
and that debate itself of course doesn't
make commitments as to work towards the
end of that process I would hope that
that we would see that bill being passed
and therefore the treaty ratified but it
will be open to have that debate while
that bill is progressing through this
house Jeremy Lefroy speaker soft and
right honourable ladies of Dom Valley
has spoken with a great deal of common
sense would would my right honourable
friend spell out what she has heard will
be the consequences for our economy
of leaving without a deal well can I say
to my honourable friend the vabis to be
a number of bits of analysis of have
been done in relation to the impact of
leaving without a deal I think there
would be an immediate impact
economically of leaving without a deal
now over time of course we could restore
our fortunes but I think it is much
better to be in a position where we're
leaving with a deal which will unleash I
believe significant business investment
in this country and see that positive
future for our economy that's possible
by leaving with a deal I've been
listening to these Prime Minister
respond to several questions about the
consequences of no deal given what's
likely to happen in the European
Parliament elections tomorrow and in the
Conservative Party leadership election
to follow on which he has filed a
starting gun does she regret
legitimizing and normalizing an ordeal
outcome in the minds of the public
through the repetition of the mantra No
Deal is better I think no government
could have gone into a situation where
it said that it would accept whatever it
was offered rather than be willing to
see no deal if they would if it had been
a bad deal but then I stand by what I
said in relation to that matter but I
also say to right honourable gentlemen
that anybody sitting in this chamber who
believes that we should not have a No
Deal situation has to support a deal
that is the way of making sure we leave
not with a No Deal so and that is the
vehicle for doing that for determining
the details of that leaving is the
withdrawal agreement bill those would be
two Bottomly unlike 1831 the 1832 Reform
Bill got through because some of those
who opposed the government did not vote
against it and that led to progress can
I say there's a national interest
conservative I have by choice voted with
the government on every single vote
because I think it's right and can I say
that I hope that others who think that
No Deal is bad and trying to reverse
referendum is bad that the majority of
both of this part
this house in the country would first
see the withdrawal agreement bill get
through at least get some second reading
so we can make progress and have a
chance of maybe a better future for our
country if we get through the second
reading we can then determine the
details through the progress of the bill
of the precise nature of our leaving
that will enable us to see progress for
this country and I believe and just to
pick up what my own will friend said I
believe that it is absolutely in the
national interest that we should leave
the European Union as the referendum
vote said but that we should do it with
a good deal for this country and that is
what is on offer my right honourable
friend asked the prime minister if she
was intending to offer a free vote on
the second referendum I'd like to ask
her the same question about the customs
arrangements which are she know are
extremely important for manufacturing
industry would it be her plan to offer a
free vote on on those customs
arrangements they do the Honourable lady
that asked in the normal progress of
these things within decisions will be
taken when we see what the proposals are
that are on the table but can I just
also reiterate the point that I made in
response to her right honourable friend
that it is not simply when you look at
the issues around manufacturing industry
the key issues that have been raised are
yes the benefits of a customs union
those are in the political declaration
already but also ensuring that we were
reducing the friction for trade at the
border that is not just about customs it
isn't just about customs but the
benefits of the customs union are in
that political declaration already yes
Lincolnshire grandi Sir Edward Lee so
ground mr. speaker but just a question
as the prime minister knows of my warm
personal support for I vote if I heard
deal not once not twice not three times
I have to say as somebody wishes a well
and which is agreement well I'm worried
about the tactics of all this I thought
that we'd agree with you we're going to
have binding indicative votes which
would have enabled people like me to
express our opposition to
the customs union or a referendum and
then vote for the withdrawal agreement
now but it's not necessary because
Parliament could do it anyway I've been
asked to vote for a bill which has on
the face of it a nod towards a second
referendum which I believe would be
disastrous to the Union and to the vast
majority of people who voted brexit so
can I just ask her to be very cautious
to listen to our party to remember that
the one vote we won was on the Brady
amendment and if we can't get this
through given the incalculable disaster
of losing this bill not being able to
bring it back again this session that if
necessary we'll think again and not
bring it back my motto my friends refers
to the case of the indicative votes of
course what I'm proposing and what I've
put forward is that during the passage
of the bill it will be possible to
address these issues and come to those
binding decisions on the issues
particularly the one that he represented
are dis of what indicated votes have
been taken what decisions have been put
into the bill had that been the way of
we had progressed from those indicative
votes on these issues those matters
would have been skirt in scope within
the bill it would still be impossible to
put for people to put other amendments
down to those to that position and for
people to vote differently from the way
in which they voted in the indicative
votes so that is why I think it is
better to bring these matters to the
point of decision which will be the
point within the bill where people are
deciding not just to indicate a position
but actually what position comes into
legislation mr. Barry Sherman okay his
fee is the premise for where that I
sincerely want her to help her get this
deal through a good deal through this
house because she helped me my good
common sense folk into Huddersfield who
are very clever people they are saying
to me after three years now we know the
full consequences of leaving the
European Union why can't they have a
chance to say what they think of the
deal once it comes out his house
the gentleman that I mean obviously I've
responded to similar points from his
honorable and right honourable
colleagues already this afternoon but
the point is that it will be possible
within the debate on the withdrawal
agreement bill and even the right
honourable gentleman wants to put a
decision back to the people of course it
has to have a deal as I think he
indicated at the end of his question to
do that might means getting the
withdrawal agreement bill through and
but it will be possible for the house to
determine within that withdrawal
agreement bill its position on this
matter the house has as he will know
rejected a second referendum on a number
of occasions already but at the point at
which it takes that decision within the
within the bill I think it will be
making that decision in a different
environment and but as I say my position
continues to be that we should deliver
on the first referendum o choice between
such distinguished colleagues mr. Jacob
Riis MOG Thank You mr. speaker
my right honourable friend must have
noticed the response in this house and
the response overnight to her statement
in proposing this folderol is she going
through the motions or does she really
believe in it honourable friend I don't
think I would have been standing here at
the despatch-box and being receipt of
some of the comments that I've been
receipt on from colleagues on my own
side and across the the house if I
didn't believe in what I was in what I
was doing I'm doing it because I
genuinely believe it is in the national
interest for us to leave the European
Union with a deal the only way to get a
deal through is to get and withdraw an
agreement built through this house there
are issues this house disagrees on and I
believe those issues should be put to
the house and the house will determine
those issues and it will be at that
point that this house and all members of
this house will have to come to some
decisions at the moment it has been
possible through indicative votes to
give indications but actually they
haven't been decisions that will be put
into legislation when the time comes to
look at this matter these will be
decisions about what should be going
ahead in terms of the government's
position on this
and what should be in legislation and
people will not be able to dock the
issues it will be necessary to come to
agreements doesn't eat a chance her from
a sedentary position like that he's a
very industrial representative on house
bill but the old gentleman of the North
East Somerset has just used a noun which
I hazard a guess has probably not been
used on any other occasion in this
Parliament or if it has only by the
Honorable gentleman
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're grateful to the honorable
gentleman mr. Peter Carr Thank You mr.
speaker what I welcome most about the
statement yesterday was its change in
tone markedly different from the ones
that are gone before can I also express
gratitude to the prime minister the
amount of time she has personally spent
with members from across the house
including myself through which she has
disagreed with but engaged with in
recent weeks it is clear though that the
contents of the statement yesterday has
widened division is not actually healed
divisions going forward can I urge her
in the two weeks before this bill comes
before Parliament and this house to
carry on that engagement with an open
mind and enter into discussions at least
about what could be changed on the face
of the bill going into second into the
committee stage in which case we will
all have something to talk about at
least otherwise it's not even worth
burning it forward in the first place
obviously I'm happy to continue engaging
across the house as I have been and I
thank him for his for his comments can I
also suggest that as his right
honourable friend the medal for Don
Valley said earlier I think it will be
helpful to all members of the house to
wait and see when the bill is published
what the actual terms of the bill are he
is encouraging me to put a position on
the face of the bill with which I do not
agree but I think it is right that what
we do in the bill is enable this house
to come to a decision on that particular
issue tonight who represents a beautiful
forest
so there's McSwain by the end of July
she says a brexit here of whatever
flavor could grab the bill a second
reading saving their reservations for
committee and make their final judgment
at third reading
couldn't they and what is a folder roll
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I think there are different
definitions sherry and useless item
allegedly or a an unnecessary or
inconsequential fossils I mean but
that's only the honorable gentleman's
view of the matter I'm not expressing
any view on that matter at all I was
just intrigued by the endless lexicon of
the Honorable gentlemen the Prime
Minister Thank You mr. speaker and I
have to say I think when our honourable
friend the mental North East Somerset
used that word he was not intending it
to be complimentary about the package
that they but the government has been
brought forward now my right honorable
friend is absolutely right of course for
the bill to get through for it to be
ratified for the treaty to be ratified
for us to be able to leave at the end of
July it's not only getting second
reading through but also ensuring that
the bill is confirmed at at third
reading but by getting through second
reading it's possible to have those
debates within the structure of as the
progress of the bill on the key issues
that remain on the key issues in which
the remain disagreement between members
of this house such that it will be
possible I believe to come to an
agreement that can see us leave the
European Union was DB kiddo
mr. speaker the Prime Minister's made it
clear that she does not intend to put a
commitment to a second referendum on the
face of the bill at second reading in
the spirit of compromise therefore would
she commit to giving her MPs a free vote
at committee stage when we come to
debate and vote on that measure as I
said what we will put on the what we are
intending to put in the bill is the
commitment to have a vote on whether to
have a second referendum and that the
bill cannot be ratified until that vote
has